hey everyone welcome back to our Channel
today we have an exciting topic to
discuss and that show to pick the
interest of all the aspiring ethical
hackers out there we will be diving deep
into the top skills required for ethical
hacking whether you are a beginner
looking to get started or a seasoned Pro
looking to refine your skills this video
has something for everyone and before
starting if you are an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
a right choice this course is designed
to accommodate a diverse range of
Learners and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% average and
no prior programming experience and one
plus year of work experience is
preferred for more details you can use
the tap link mentioned in the
description box below and pin comment so
let's get started so first we'll have an
introduction to ethical hacking that is
before we delve into the skills let's
first understand what ethical hacking is
ethical hackers also known as Whitehead
hackers are cyber Security Experts who
legally breach systems to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses their
mission is to protect organizations and
individuals from cyber threats and to
become a successful ethical hacker you
need to master several key skills so
let's get started with the key skills so
the first skill is excellent computer
skills to become an effective ethical
hacker you first need excellent computer
skills this involves quickly grasping
and utilizing new technologies thinking
creatively to identify potential
vulnerabilities exploiting those
vulnerabilities and documenting your
work for replication without these core
skills it's challenging to perform
ethical hacking effectively moving to
the next skill that is strong foundation
in networking so the skill you need is a
strong foundation in networking you must
understand how Network operate including
protocols IP addressing subnets and
routers without this knowledge you won't
be able to effectively analyze and
secure network systems and then comes
the third skill that is Proficiency in
in operating systems so skill number
three is Proficiency in operating
systems an ethical hacker should be
comfortable with the variety of os
platforms such as Windows Linux and Mac
OS this knowledge is essential for
understanding vulnerabilities and
exploiting them Linux is an invaluable
operating system for ethical hackers it
provides access to system internals and
potential vulnerabilities Linux skills
empowers haers to create custom scripts
and programs for task automation
hands-on experience with various Linux
distributions is the most effective way
to learn and customize tools and
techniques and then comes the next skill
that is programming and scripting so
programming skills are fundamental to
ethical hacking ethical hackers use
their coding knowledge to discover
vulnerabilities and propose Solutions
Common programming languages used in
ethical hacking include python Java or p
HP a strong understanding of coding is
necessary to comprehend how systems
operate and where weaknesses might hide
so this was the fourth skill now moving
to the next skill that is database
skills so ethical hackers must Master
database skills understanding how
databases are structured and function is
crucial for identifying security
vulnerabilities Proficiency in database
management tools enables hackers to
manipulate data and access restrict
restricted information that is a vital
skill for the job crafting SQL queries
to extract information from database is
essential to find vulnerabilities an
ethical hackers deep knowledge of how
databases work and how to use SQL for
manipulation is a critical skill now
moving to the next skill that is the
sixth skill and that is understanding of
cyber security Concepts an in-depth
understanding of cyber security Concepts
is a must you should be well versed in
cyber security models encryption access
control and risk management knowing how
malicious hackers operate will help you
defend against them now moving to the
next skill that is web application
security web application security is
crucial in today's digital landscape you
need to be skilled in identifying and
fixing vulnerabilities like SQL
injection crite scripting and cross site
request forgery to protect web
applications from attacks now moving to
the next skill that is familiarity with
security tools familiarity with security
tools is skill number tools like wi
shock meta exploit and map and BB suit
are essential for scanning analyzing and
exploiting bu abilities mastering these
tools will give you a significant
advantage and then comes the next skill
that is cryptography cryptography plays
a crucial role in ethical hacking it
involves encrypting and decrypting in
information to protect data from
unauthorized access ethical hackers use
cryptography to safeguard information
and create back doors into systems
allowing access to sensitive data
without raising alarms and then comes
the next skill that is problem solving
and critical thinking ethical hackers
should have strong problem solving and
critical thinking skills you will often
encounter complex security challenges
that require Creative Solutions being
able to think outside the box is a
valuable skill and then comes the next
skill that is continuous learning our
final skill is a commitment to
continuous learning the world of cyber
security evolves rapidly and new threats
and techniques emerge all the time
staying up to date with the latest
trends and Technologies is vital to
maintaining your Effectiveness as an
ethical hacker and now moving to job
roles and average salary for various
cyber security roles starting with
security analyst so the average salary
in us for security analyst is
$150,000 and in India it's 11 lakhs
perom and if we talk about the
penetration tester and now moving to the
next to that is penetration tester and
the average salary for penetration
tester in US is
$145,000 perom and in India it's 13
lakhs perom and the next role is
security consultant and the average
salary in us for this role is$ 120,000
perom and in India it's 10 lakhs perom
and moving to the next role that is
security engineer and the average salary
for this role in US is
$156,000 perom and in India it is 8
lakhs perom moving to the next role that
is incident responder and the average
salary for this role in US is
$15,000 perom and in India it's 7 lakhs
perom and now moving to the companies
hiring cyber Security Professionals and
the top most companies are Amazon asenta
Google Apple and Intel and in conclusion
ethical hacking is a challenging but
immensely rewarding field that Demands a
diverse set of core Tech skills these
skills from computer proficiency to
critical thinking enable ethical hackers
to safeguard computer systems and
networks from potential threats if you
looking to enter this exciting domain
make sure to develop and refine these
skills thank you for joining us to today
and if you found this video informative
and valuable please like And subscribe
to our channel for more insights into
the world of ethical hacking stay
curious stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ND up and get certified click
here